if you lived in China in the mid 20th
century you would be very familiar with
the concept of struggle sessions during
these displays of ritual humiliation
those judged to be enemies of the regime
were publicly denounced and shamed a
Wall Street Journal op-ed a few years
ago described these ceremonies quote in
the struggle sessions the accused often
teachers suspected of lacking
proletarian feeling were paraded through
streets and campuses sometimes stadiums
it was important always to have a
jeering crowd it was important that the
electric feeling that comes with the
possibility of murder be present dunce
caps sometimes waste back baskets were
placed on the victim's head and placards
stipulating their crimes hung from their
necks the victims were accused berated
assaulted many falsely confessed in the
vain hope of Mercy where any guilty it
hardly mattered fear and Terror were the
point a destroyed Society is more easily
dominated now an important feature of
the struggle session is that friends and
colleagues and spouses and children were
set against the person who'd been used
those closest to the class enemy had to
show their loyalty to the regime by
betraying their friends or even their
own blood the point behind all this was
to get the alleged wrongdoer to confess
and repent whether they were guilty of
any crime or not like it said it hardly
mattered whether they were guilty
sometimes though it took a lot of
persuading in the Wall Street Journal
article offers a vivid anecdote of what
was sometimes involved in this uh quote
the Chinese Catholic Margaret Chu a
medical lab assistant was dragged into
the office of her labor camp in 1968 and
made to answer invented charges quote
their real motive was once and again to
force me to admit all my alleged crimes
she wrote decades later I did not commit
any crimes I asserted she was accused
again roughed up she denied her guilt
quote immediately two people jumped on
me and cut off half my hair she was
tortured left in handcuffs for a hundred
days and in prison for years while being
tortured she sometimes prayed for death
so her suffering would stop
now
that was a struggle session in maoist
China in the 1960s but you've probably
heard the phrase used to describe
circumstances in Western Society in the
year 2023 and we do indeed have our own
version of these humiliation rituals in
our case the methods used to disgrace
and humiliate the accused will often be
less violent often often less violent
not always
but in many ways that only makes the
humiliation worse in the end
I mean it's one thing to fold after
weeks of physical torture almost anyone
would
it's another thing to fold after a few
hours of mean comments on the internet
but for many people that's all it takes
the post-millennial reports on just the
latest example of this quote Toronto
Blue Jays pitcher Anthony bass
apologized on Tuesday for sharing a
social media post that explained why
Christians should participate in
boycotting companies like Target and Bud
Light who have been at the height of
national scrutiny over their failed
marketing campaigns chocked full of
lgbtq propaganda bass briefly shared the
faith-based video to his Instagram
stories on Monday evening which called
on Christians to stop patronizing U.S
companies that go against biblical
teachings but then quickly deleted it
following backlash according to USA
Today the original video that bash
shared took aim at those companies
saying quote here's the reason
biblically why I believe Christians have
got to be boycotting Target Bud Light
and any other Corporation that's pushing
the things they're pushing this is evil
this is demonic we won't stand for it
we're not going to go to the stores
anymore and we're not going to give you
our money
that's what the video said
despite the post only being up for a
brief amount of time it was long enough
for the outrage mob to come after bass
who claims to be a devout Christian now
that very mild Instagram video
uh which just points out just says
what's happening We're not gonna go to
the stores anymore calls it demonic
which it literally is I mean Target was
actually selling satanic merchandise
that's what they did
posted for only a brief period of time
uh was enough to provoke outrage from
the left and uh it was helped Along by
bass's own team throwing him under the
bus of course the Blue Jays put out a
statement clarifying that quote
individual player sentiments are not
representative of the club's beliefs and
then the team went on to explain that
quote the Blue Jays bring millions of
fans together across Canada and are
committed to providing an inclusive and
welcoming experience for all the Blue
Jays are proud to celebrate
lgbtq2s plus pride month including a
special fourth annual uh pride pride
weekend at the Ballpark June 9th and
10th and demonstrations of allyship all
month long around the ballpark
that's what the team said and then bass
followed a short time later with his own
groveling statement
watch
I recognized yesterday I made a post
that was hurtful to the pride Community
which includes friends of mine and close
family members of mine and I am truly
sorry for that
um I just spoke with my teammates took
and shared within my actions yesterday I
apologize with them
and as right now I'm using the Blue Jays
resources to better educate myself to
make better decisions moving forward uh
the ballpark is for everybody we include
all fans at the Ballpark and we want to
welcome everybody that's all I have to
say thank you
I made a post I made a post that was
hurtful it was a hurtful post
the ballpark's for everybody what did he
say that would contradict that when did
he ever imply that the ballpark isn't
for everybody did Anthony bass say that
gay people aren't welcome at the Toronto
Blue Jays stadium
is that what he said
did he say that if he sees a gay person
that stands he's going to throw a line
drive right at their faces I mean is
that what he said
he didn't say anything about gay people
he was talking about targets and Bud
Lights
well are there fans that would hear that
Anthony bass supports boycotting Bud
Light and Target and then interpret that
as uh they aren't welcome in the stadium
because they're gay or whatever are
there fans who would interpret it that
way if they would interpret it that way
that's their problem
okay if you're that stupid and that's
sensitive that you feel like you're not
even welcome in a stadium because one
guy on the field has a point of view
that you disagree with that's your
problem
it's not anybody else's problem the CEO
of innovation refunds and getrefunds.com
has been on TV explaining how they've
helped so many small businesses with
their ERC tax refunds they've completed
thousands of returns for different kinds
of businesses including over 700 million
dollars for construction companies and
over 200 million dollars in restaurants
bars and hotels Innovation refunds has
hundreds of five-star trust pilot and
Google reviews and it's certified with
the Better Business Bureau in just eight
minutes you can easily start the process
on getrefunds.com you could be on your
way to receiving up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee you don't
want to miss out on that the ERC tax
credit is not a loan it's a refund of
your already paid taxes designed to let
the business owner direct the refund
money into anything the business needs
to grow it's money that you can use to
improve your business however you see
fit so go to getrefunds.com to start the
process there's no upfront charge they
don't get paid unless you get paid
Innovation refunds has already helped
clients claim over five billion dollars
in payroll tax refunds through the ERC
and they may be able to help your
business too so go to getrefunds.com or
download the app from the app store
today that's getrefunds.com today
did you know that our friends at genu
cell have upgraded their most popular
package to feature their top selling
deep firming vitamin C serum plus Ultra
retinal moisturizer with natural retinal
alternative you probably didn't but now
you do because right now you can take
advantage of this limited time package
upgrade for 70 off why waste time and
money to go get work done on your face
when you can get genucel skin care
shipped right to your door genius house
secret is a family recipe for over 20
years that makes it safe for all skin
types and perfect for both men and women
made by a compounding pharmacist and
small batches and it's always safe
cruelty free and natural as well you
know our show intern Holly is already
starting to develop disgusting under eye
bags after working here for only a few
weeks I told her if she doesn't get that
horrendous flaw under control I won't be
able to trust her to work on my show I
only accept people with perfect faces
like mine working on this show so Holly
has done the only thing that can be done
the situation and has started using genu
cell go to genusel.com Walsh and try
Jenny cell's most popular package for 70
off featuring both genucel's Ultra
retinal and genucel's Firming Serum get
a complimentary Spa Essentials box with
every package order plus free upgrade to
Priority ship and go to genucel.com
Walsh that's genucel.com Walsh
now as we know the left loves nothing
more than to castrate people especially
children but not every castration is
performed medically what you just
witnessed is more of a spiritual and
emotional castration
that was a man utterly debasing himself
sacrificing his dignity and his
masculinity on the LGBT altar giving up
everything
forfeiting his good name his
self-respect all in exchange once again
for nothing
the LGBT mob as always demands total
acquiescence absolute submission you
must give up your values your beliefs
your sense of right and wrong your
common sense your faith your
understanding of basic biological
reality your soul
and in return
they give you nothing
that's the deal
they say to you like they said to
Anthony bass you give us everything and
we will give you nothing nothing but
more demands and more accusations
because nothing is ever good enough
that's why the activist media responded
to this apology by demanding that
Anthony bass still be fired Yahoo sports
published an article by Nick Ashbourne
with this headline Blue Jays can't
roster Anthony bass and keep his views
at arm's length
Ashbourne goes on to explain that quote
when bash shared a video to his
Instagram story that strongly endorsed
boycotting Target due to the company's
Pro
lgbtq2s Plus initiatives
he took the step from controversy into
bigotry as long as he's wearing a blue
jays uniform that's a stain the club
can't scrub out
he's a stain
referring to a person as a stain
and then he then spent several
paragraphs demanding that the baseball
player's career should come to an end
and warning that his team better not
stand by him quote in any way shape or
form
his team has received this message by
the way loud and clear the Blue Jays
manager manager told the media yesterday
that quote we're not going to pretend
like this never happened we're not going
to pretend like it's the end and move on
there are definitely more steps that are
going that we're going to have to follow
this is what Anthony bass gets for
Bowing before the LGBT called and
apologizing for daring to have his own
point of view
the consequence that he was trying to
avoid will likely happen regardless
see the left they take hostages they
make demands and then they receive the
ransom and they execute the hostage
anyway
this is how it goes every single time
and yet somehow their Ransom demands are
still met every single time
or or almost every time
keep in mind also that Anthony bass is
35 years old he's a multi-millionaire
he's near the end of his baseball career
anyway
what would he really lose by simply
standing by his own words what what is
actually at stake for him
now there are some who um
want to make excuses for Anthony bass
and all the Anthony basses of the world
all the other people who who the cowards
who cave to the slightest pressure from
the left and they say that we can't know
what it's like to be in their position
it's easy to judge from a distance
well I can tell you that I am not
judging from a distance okay
I'm in the thick of it too
and I can say that yes
you know the average person doesn't
fully understand nor do they anticipate
the level of outrage they will encounter
if they wade into these Waters they do
not realize just how vicious and
personal and ruthless the LGBT cult can
be when you dare to disagree with them
publicly
the moment you cross them you have
unpersoned yourself in their eyes you
are not a human anymore
you are some sort of animal to be caged
and tranquilized and maybe put down
they will try to beat you down they will
rip you to shreds they will absolutely
set out to destroy your life and the
lives of anyone close to you I I have I
have tried to explain this many times
okay I have talked about my own
experiences how my opposition to the
LGBT agenda and trans ideology has led
to me being doxxed and hacked and
threatened and smeared relentlessly and
Without End every day
when I say for instance that my family
needs 24-hour armed security in our home
I am not saying that for dramatic effect
it's literally true
and and the reason that I share these
experiences though I haven't even told
you that half of it trust me
is that
I want people to be prepared for the
fight that they're getting themselves
into I don't want them to be blindsided
that's why I talk about this
and yet people still don't know what
it's like until they see it up close
they just don't know until they see it
okay because it's true if you stand off
at a distance and you've never really
gone up against this mob in any kind of
substantive way
and then you hear from people who have
and they try to tell you what it's like
it's easy to sell you're it's not that
bad come on you're exaggerating
and then the the letters start coming to
your home from Anonymous senders
threatening you know making threats
against your family like once that
happens you realize oh okay this is
serious
but no matter how many times
we've we've warned about this invariably
people are shocked and many turn around
and run for the Hills
so
as someone who knows very well just how
Fierce and merciless the backlash can be
I still say
that there is no excuse for this kind of
cowardness
we have made too many excuses for too
long
yes it is difficult to withstand the
pressure yes the the leftist mob is
vicious and deranged
okay
so what
sometimes you simply have to just do the
difficult thing
sometimes you have to give the mob the
middle finger and let the chips fall
where they may
for years and years very few people have
been willing to do that which has only
emboldened the left and given them the
power that they now wield
and now the cowards want to use that
power imbalance as an excuse for
continuing to be cowards
no it doesn't work that way
if you're a coward it's your fault we're
in this position in the first place you
don't get to hide behind the
consequences of your own actions or
inaction in this case
enough hiding
stand up straight for a change and let
yourself be counted among the sane and
the decent
do the right thing and stick by it no
matter what happens
and if you're not willing to do that by
the way then just shut up and don't say
anything
you know that's the other alternative
it's not it's not good it's not a good
alternative but I prefer for you to say
nothing if you can't stand by what you
say then shut your mouth and don't open
it to begin with
just stay silent like everybody else
once you speak up you have an obligation
to stand by it
and if you don't
you're just as bad as the mob you're
caving to you're just as bad
I have just as much contempt for you as
I do for them
actually you're worse you're worse
because you're a traitor and a weakling
in fact because you surrender to the Mob
you deserve the treatment that you get
from them
they're going to try to try to ruin your
life anyway and so be it
you are not worth defending
if you won't even defend yourself
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there